these actors played their child roles so
convincingly that we never had any idea
they were
actually grown-ups join us as we explore
the history of adults who played kids in
movies and fooled us all
in the 2002 romantic comedy bend it like
beckham parmender nagra stars as a
london teen named jess who joins a local
women's soccer team
at the urging of her friends her natural
talent for the sport shines through and
jess is soon leading the team on its way
to the championship
in the movie jess becomes close friends
with her teammate jules played by keira
knightley
and a budding romance develops between
jess and her young and attractive coach
joe not everything is perfect though as
the championship takes place on the same
day as jess's sister's wedding
and jess's strict parents have forbidden
her to play and don't even know she's on
the team
although bend it like beckham is just a
sports themed spin on the traditional
teen romcom the star of the movie wasn't
even close to being a teenager herself
when nagra played 18 year old jess in
the film the actress was actually 26.
casting directors frequently age up when
picking actors to fill roles in team
movies and amy heckerling's 1995
coming of age comedy clueless is a
pretty classic example of this
in fact most of the main clueless cast
members were slightly older than the
characters they played in the movie
at the start of the film cher played by
alicia silverstone
is 15 years old while silverstone
herself was 17 at the time
similarly josh played by paul rudd is a
college undergraduate student while rudd
was 25 during filming
however the one clueless star that
really fooled audiences was stacy dash
who played cher's best friend
dion if you've seen clueless you might
have assumed dash was around the same
age as her on-screen classmates
in fact the actress was actually 28 when
she played the 16 year old dion
what's more dash went on to reprise her
role in 62 episodes of the clueless
television series spin-off
from 1996 to 1999. while the teens do
grow
older during the course of the show that
still left dash then in her
early 30s playing an 18 year old when
the series drew to a close
in 2004 the small indie comedy napoleon
dynamite took the world by storm
this quirky cult classic takes a look at
the awkward and awesome adventures of
high school student napoleon dynamite
played by john heater
as he navigates life in small town idaho
alongside his friend pedro who was
played by efren ramirez
filmed on a budget of just 400 000
napoleon dynamite earned over 46 million
dollars at the box office and turned
heater and ramirez
into celebrities almost overnight
that's a pretty good idea heater could
probably still pass for a high school
student today
so it may not surprise you to learn that
the babyfaced actor and producer was
actually 26 while working on napoleon
dynamite
what we really want to know is how
ramirez keeps his youthful good looks
though
not only was he nearly 30 during filming
but the mustache he grew for the part
actually made pedro look even younger
than he was supposed to be
in the classic 1987 romance dirty
dancing recent high school graduate
francis baby houseman spends a summer
with her affluent family at a resort in
the catskill mountains where she meets
dance instructor johnny castle played by
patrick swayze after baby agrees to fill
in for johnny's dance partner penny at
an upcoming performance
she and johnny grow closer as they
practice together and help penny out of
a tough situation
she may have been playing a fresh-faced
17 year old but gray was no baby when
she appeared in dirty dancing
although she definitely looked like a
typical american teenager the actress
was actually 27 years old which would
become one of her most widely remembered
roles
in fact in 2020 it was announced that
gray would be reprising her
unforgettable role in a sequel to the
original movie
even if you've never read a single one
of jk rowling's wildly popular harry
potter books you're likely familiar with
the minor character moaning myrtle
though you might not have known her name
myrtle is one of the many ghosts that
haunt hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry and her first big screen
appearance came during 2002's harry
potter and the chamber of secrets
in that film harry ron and hermione
learn more about myrtle and how she died
during some uncomfortable encounters in
the bathroom she likes to haunt
her exact age isn't specified in the
harry potter movies or books but context
clues suggest she was killed when she
was around 13 or 14 years old
looks like mining myrtles flooded the
bathroom believe it or not scottish
actress shirley henderson was actually
37 when she first appeared as the
distressed ghost in 2002's chamber of
secrets
this makes her by far the oldest actor
to portray a hogwarts student on screen
ghosts don't age of course so henderson
later beat her own record when she
reprised the role of myrtle in 2005's
harry potter and the goblet of fire at
age 39.
in the 1996 comedy the bird cage robin
williams stars as
armond goldman an openly gay man who
owns a drag queen club
in south beach near the start of the
film armond learns that his son val
played by dan futterman is in love with
18 year old barbara keely played by ally
mcbeal favorite kalista flockhart the
only problem is barbara is the daughter
of a prominent florida senator and she
worries about how her conservative
parents will react if they learn the
truth about armand's lifestyle
as a result armond agrees to pretend to
be straight when the keeley's come for a
visit
even arranging for val's mother to
pretend to be his wife
as you might expect things don't work
out quite according to plan
although calista flockhart and the rest
of the birdcage cast were mostly a
backdrop for the comedic talent of the
late robin williams
flockhart did a convincingly good job in
her role as the nervous 18 year old
barbara
her performance was especially
impressive considering the fact that she
was actually 31 during filming
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one